[Music]  Jon Gosselin is becoming a stripper so  that's kind of like let's just get that  out yep you heard that right the former  reality star turned DJ confirmed the  news to et Saturday when rumors began to  swirl after Jon posted this telling  poster to Instagram that he would be  performing as a male entertainer at the  untamed male revue show in Atlantic City  New Jersey a father of eight tells et  I'm an integral part of the show being  part of something is a blessing since I  joined I felt like I belonged to  something and I'm not just out there on  my own I feel as if I'm part of a  fraternity or Brotherhood a 39 year old  DJ also revealed exclusively to ET his  first night performing at the nightclub  is April first  [Music]  you